talk to Mike Mat mat the center right for
Doc he'll skate it in for Montreal doc docs
protects the buck mat left side floats one in
and an oh rebound score right to right your
slowski little momentum for big number 20 two
now in the preseason it's one nothing Montreal
watching this opening draw a little smile from
I slavkovsky he's thinking we have a big game
tonight all starts with Kirby doc though on the
rush turns it up finds Madison pucks to the net
that's the key to Mike Madison and the coach has
talked about the number of touches SL kovski can
get during a game Pary Keller sends it in Samuel
monmo starting goalie for the Montreal Canadians
tonight Kelly finds the puck feeds the line that
R shot deflected in front it was Mark castle at
good screen and in front score buried in front the
followup by Parker Kelly and we're tied up that
[Applause] one mark the thought talked about
Parker Kelly before the game as a guy we should
be watching he's got to be part of an energy
line with castle and Taran fizer playing in
his first National League game ever going to get a
point here on this Parker Kelly goal that's where
Parker Kelly has to hang out Mike Mat at the
line Suzuki accepts WS fored monan good get to
stick on that field for mat back to Coffield M the
Brie shot up by rebound mon in front through the
crease crawled out to soard up to Coffield delay
shoots and again soar down it out and he found
away to stop number 22 Harris tried to feather
it in front for a Hyman that was broken up nice
little pass fin space tight the forhead big stop
as Josh Bailey I think that this is the first time
I've seen this type of pace in an exhibition game
but I think that is because there are a couple of
goals scored early and when that happens you know
everybody thinks they can get something going and
the energy gets ratcheted up Evans up St petta
score quick strike Michael petta and it's 21 of
Montreal Jake Evans a good Scrappy Faceoff win he
follows the puck to the wall and the Harris pass
and then just that little slide up to by space
knowing where that space is in the offensive
zone watch Michael bazett's route here as soon
as he knows the puck is in good shape he loads
up and he stays outside a little bit high for the
right to do that tonight guys Claire that's such
a cool story and in talking to Yuri and having
some time with him before the game earlier today
what a well spoken thoughtful young man he was
one of the ones involved in the last one on a
Las change to give it going again soar got just
enough to stop that as Harris was cruising in
from the back end up finishing his body check bar
boards norlander tangled up at Center Buck of the
Ottawa Blue Line cik finds it pin balls though
right to Suzuki Suzuki to R score the captain
Nick Suzuki back of the net for his six point
of the pre-season Montreal by [Applause] two
he doesn't spring early little casual there
cast trying to come across the middle which
you can't do and that is an excellent shot by
Suzuki pulls it across so he can use branstrom
as a screen watch him employ branstrom he doesn't
have it at first so he delays just a little bit to
hide the puck a little bit more picked off nicely
here's BR granstrom beating in he's got Greg with
him granstrom cross kubik what a goal kubik UPS
off with a goal scorer snipe and Ottawa within
one
Elite ging there branstrom a little bit more
open ice out there he picks it up without
hesitation watch ly Greg Drive the middle
that takes a little bit of space away then
all branom has to worry about is the Stick of
Justin Baron so as soon as he can find the lane
across getting closer and closer to that
regular season underway third period
Montreal on the penalty kill there is mat
and he'll backand it in I think Matt sard
has a bright future in the Ottawa Senators
organization 21 career NHL games for soard
as the 22-year-old continues to make his
Mark cutting in what a goal Roby jenti
out of nowhere takes the puck right
through the wickets we're tied up at
[Applause] [Music] three three three
tie third period nice hands jarvi able
to finish and tight as the Ottawa second
rounder from 2020 16 goals in bbo they got
another they go back to back
Ridley Greg and Ottawa leads
43 Ridley Greg who at a strong game tonight I
just spoke about play impression a mishandle
first by montambo and then a second
mishandle by Jordan Harris in tight
Greg stays with it find a way and a
little smile a 4-3 lead for the Ottawa
Senators Tes after it around the board picked
up by Coffield Coffield little spin move drops
it off Heria up top norlander they'll work it
across little puck Bobble back up to norlander
ther fires tip score the tip in front some sweet
hands and the Montreal Canadians have come all the
way back they've tied it up 44 who the veteran
has the tip in front from number 91 d a good
game tonight a couple of excellent passes and
nolander just gets it through and just a touch
by John Monahan affecting the screen in front
of the net as well as the stick position monell
with a good pit norlander actually had three
or four chances himself there butell finds a
way to get one 6 minutes and 3 seconds left in
this hockey game they're not going away you're
right over to Harris Harris works it in for Harvey
Berard Harvey Berard below the goal line takes
contact Suzuki his turn to work hary pinard in
front quick shot score call Coffield 54 [Applause]
Montreal get a slick little pass Ridley Greg loses
control of the puck and Nick Suzuki just manages
to get it out to Harvey perard I think just goes
off Travis hamik in front of the net up and over
the shoulder of Matt sogard who's battled hard
tonight and soard thought about go to the bench
with 209 to go but he'll Retreat trying to get
that extra attacker out as Monahan's on the buck
Monahan Jack ey rer off the pipe Harper Jacky
nearly brought the insurance down at Canadian
dire Center as that rer off is thick and wide
he was walking right in and was that close to
sealing things for the pree check this out ooh
that might have well the twine you the twine was
tickled they gone in the net that went right
through the that's a goal that is a goal that
is after further review the puck went
through the net therefore it is a good
goal 202 there was a year playing with
Mar how when I didn't see him until the
3 days before the season started not
once he was in a different exhibition
games all the way along and we introduced
ourselves and went out and play the season